pour cette dernière semaine je veux que
du top of the top
alors j'ai appelé plusieurs personnes et
familles et on va revenir dessus dans l
instant il ya le conseil de classe de
gilles verdez et il y avait comme ce
soir deux aides alors là r je suis comme
un génie pour cette dernière semaine je
veux que du top of the top
alors j'ai appelé plusieurs personnes
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine je veux que du top c'est
pour ça que je voulais démarrer le top
la semaine en folie avec mady de magdala
et décalé qui décale j'adore ça rigole
égal pendant le direct dirait douze
entraîneurs de foot 1 qui compte une
équipe bretonne est abattu mais cela
tend vers lui que rien à voir mais ce
qui fait quand même c'est un super film
valérie benaïm moi j'ai adoré d'abord
j'ai trouvé que alors je te le dit malik
1 mais tu étais solaire un certain mais
c'est vrai c'est pas des crèmes solaires
[Applaudissements]
et oui mais il va du lean est d'une
facilité et eli est formidable en petit
merdouille vraiment d'une ville on
reviendra sur ce garçon qui a eu
apparemment ses papiers et son visa
grâce à une action vise à grasse
attouchements aux postes et nous
expliquera tout ça dans un instant que
ce serait quelqu'un avec nous dans leur
mission ces genres de personnes
merci sam hamad et il a eu très peu
maintenant c'est bon attaquant alors ils
tombèrent plateau mon frère on n'a pas
ici il est bon il est complet mais c'est
comme ça ma mère elle sert le thé dessus
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est atteint se prend pourtant dysport
dans les coeurs double il ya beaucoup de
messages également sur toi stéphane de
gens qui disent c'est fragile
vétérinaire non parce que tu marches
oui mais voilà mais on va vous expliquer
cette année il voit là et de bonnes
idées mais ses fans en fait ils voient
la mêlée à lourdes juste après
il joue même voter die même ajouté isna
on a bien fait des matches tous les deux
où elle était et est debout a expliqué
paris j'aime bien venir sur les plateaux
et puis sur le coup deux bouts parce que
je ne savais pas que le tennis en
fauteuil et n'étaient pas réservés aux
personnes qui étaient en fauteuil au
quotidien il se trouve que moi je suis
amputée de ma jambe gauche au dessus de
salou et j'aimerais bien même que tout
le monde puisse un jour et demi vous
avez envie de jouer l'an passé la jambe
au 613 amputé pas puissent partager
comme dans les séries je me sens tout
vous dire les deux personnes c'est
étonnant mais n'ont pas dit non l or
elles n'ont elles n'ont pas dit oui
parce que pour l'instant le sentent pas
d'émissions non mais la production s'est
classé 18e exactement mon cas mon séjour
à temps pour savoir qui aura d'autres je
veux le suivre comme l'a pour l'instant
il ya pour l'instant c'est dans celle du
parquet frères non
vous donnez des doubles à dire au point
où ils sont où ils en sont ces qui m'ont
appelé non mais jure sur ma visite j'ai
moi aussi mais non vraiment pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]